hey guys my name is Jess it's the
thusser December and the game awards are
on today so if you're tuning in be sure
to frantically tweet me your highlight
for now or let's do gaming news first up
today red dead redemption is coming to
pc and ps4 through playstation now
rockstar have revealed that the ps3
version of the cowboy centric game will
arrive on the video game streaming
service on december six PlayStation now
allows its games to be played on a
variety of devices oh yeah technically
red dead redemption has now finally made
it to PC thought of alongside this
release will be the zombie riffic undead
nightmare expansion for you to enjoy as
you wait on the release of red dead
redemption to next up that no man's sky
investigation where hello games were
being accused of misleading advertising
has been resolved the Advertising
Standards Authority ruled that hello
games did not mislead consumers through
the screenshots and videos posted on the
game steam page and that advertising
codes were not breached the a-si
explained we consider that the overall
impression of the ad was consistent with
gameplay and the footage provided both
in terms of that captured by hello games
and by third parties and that it did not
exaggerate the expected player
experience of the game 23 parties that
brought the game to the attention of the
a-si claiming that it was not as
depicted or described through marketing
material the a as they concluded that
due to the procedural generation in no
man's sky it's fair to expect specific
things in the ad to be representative of
the players experience rather than
identical to it for the full ruling
check out our story on games blood
finally a CFO Blake Jorgensen has said
that the star wars battlefront sequel
will be much bigger speaking at an
investor briefing in Europe eogan ssin
kicked off by saying there won't be
another battlefield game for a while
explaining you might need to wait until
2018 or later for your next battlefield
fix he said that for the next
installment EA are trying to provide
additional opportunities for the player
to engage and they want to deepen
engagement without disturbing the
gameplay a like into this happening
successfully to FIFA's ultimate
mode regarding star wars battlefront
Jorgensen said if there was criticism
they just wanted more oh we're taking
that criticism to heart as we build the
next game and trying to address any of
the issues that they had he called the
battlefront sequel much bigger and more
exciting star wars battlefront 2 is
reportedly going to arrive in the fall
of next year let me know down in the
comments what you cared about today head
to gain slot for a final fantasy 15 tips
and I was viewing in tomorrow